all right angel yeah angel oh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally uh
right i grew up
in on planet earth
uh
i was
a racer with different groups of family
so i was kind of
like passed around
as a growing up i got to be with the
different parts of my family different
like uh
family heads i guess you know
in los angeles yeah
[Music]
and uh
you had so your parents were part of
your life or not part of your life
ah yeah matter of fact um
i learned to uh
i learned about parenting
and then i learned uh you know like my
my my parents and then the other parents
in in the tribal community
you know and so then i i learned like
you know the whole that kind of network
of parents you know i mean like i call
it the the parenthood
like where are you from
so you're part of a you say tribal
community
i mean it sounds like a
some kind of camp or cult or something
like that
well i guess you could call it um
home
you know and um
you know
like i don't know what the house to say
you know i mean i i grew up believing in
god and then and then i entered into the
covenant with the lord jesus christ and
um
you know it's since uh since that point
everything was uh
on the way to
you know did you go to school
uh yeah i went to school and then um
like i have
like some learning disabilities and then
and then i have some learning uh uh like
really good parts too you know so
there's like you know i'm kind of a cork
yeah
have you uh
have you worked have you had jobs in
your life
uh
are you kind of
you know i've always wanted to um
do like adult entertainment and uh like
uh
body art and um i'm an artist this is my
main thing and
so i got into like uh forms you know to
me different forms of like uh
i don't know critiquing
uh a form of uh let's say drawing
you know and then uh maybe like uh try
to critique a form of style dressing you
know or
maybe uh
like uh like reiki a for you know i mean
the deep tissue rub you know critique it
to where you could get it without
hurting the tissue and then you know you
you're the the
the person who's um
also involved with the reiki healing in
the beginning i mean so
getting better form has been my goal
throughout life you know and that
reminds me you said you have parents you
know uh
yeah you know i look at it and i see the
whole community is like my parents you
know i mean at the end of the day if i
really look
at it
you know at
myself or or the world or try to
understand how things you know work or
why why things go a certain way or they
don't you know i
i'm not insecure to that you know i mean
like
you know i was raised by you know people
you know what i mean so you know i mean
did you how did you describe your
childhood would you say it was a good
childhood uh
well i actually can't really
remember too much you know i mean i i
you know i had a few
uh a lot of like uh maybe like uh
educational kind of like stuff you know
i was involved in like uh
different programming and stuff like
that and uh
i don't know like um
yeah i had fun you know like when i was
real real small i don't really remember
but i remember playing a lot
you know and then i remember you know
becoming awareness when i get sometimes
i would get into trouble or you know hey
what are you doing you know
bring me to attention you know what i
mean yeah and so then i would
and that's when i started to gain a kind
of
consciousness
and you are drugs part of your life yeah
what's uh what's your drug currently
well i started off with oxygen
and then it went to food
and then i was over my chemical balance
you know i mean and then
i i supplement
chemical balances for my uh my brain and
my my mood stabilization my coping
skills and things like that
you know
also like if i
uh
involved in like some kind of like uh
i don't know if i want to work a lot you
know what i mean like if i fight if i'm
not bored and i want to
continue to uh
function you know like work on something
or you know participate and help out
with something you know i mean sometimes
i'll uh
i'll work you know
you know 80 hours you know eating
straight on through next you know two or
three days you know i mean what will
help you do that uh
i'm pretty much just
food water and then a little bit of uh
this is the chemical balances that i
usually you know i i i maintain you know
um
food water and drugs you know the food
and drug the
thing what else you need it would just
need you know i mean the supplementation
you know yeah you know you find out what
works for you it's like you're like
exercising almost you know like
so like you know if i'm doing some long
long distance running and stuff i might
want to you know up the carbs and and
and just take stuff from my like tendons
and stuff like that so that you know i
can pace myself accordingly
or if
if i got like a
if i'm doing a you know 50 yard dash you
know coming up in this competition that
i might do i want to eat a lot more
protein and stuff like that and so
and then even then i would still want to
supplement the chemicals the stuff for
my brain you know and stuff like that so
so that i can have a balance you know
and that started you started using drugs
at what age
uh
i'm probably er young i was uh
i
i grew up in the uh
subculture of the
the drug subculture you know and um
i was you know
uh
cigarettes pills um
uh
exercise endorphins you know what i mean
food water nutrition you know i mean i
try to make your parents into drugs as
well um
i i could say you know like uh yeah they
participated in your
your tribe well yeah i know people that
do and i know people that don't you know
that are people that are openly about it
and then other people you know they just
like to keep their
their business to themselves and then
they pro-function you know what i mean
um
but uh you know i i i looked at it you
know things i tried to get a clear
understanding for myself you know
instead of
becoming uh sometimes i would
call it
overanalyze things you know or like
oh this is so bad for us you know this
is so bad this is so bad you know
what is so bad about it what is it and
then i study uh nutrition and
supplementation and things like that
that's okay what's the effect
is it helping me at all or is it is is
is is it is it hindering my process or
my progress or is it you know i mean is
it helping me
so like
if i'm if i'm using uh
amphetamines right
and uh i'm like uh
well
i'm i'm working on my uh zen sleeping
technique you know what i mean well
amphetamines probably wouldn't be that
you know
you know i mean
but if i'm working on you know uh
stay focused and and and and and being
able to concentrate and and stay on
track and have energy and
keep a
sort of a medium
uh balance of of a mood
i would go with
yeah okay
amphetamines and and a little bit of
weed every day you know
how do you support yourself
um
i i i i
i recycle i do artwork i i help out in
the community you know what i mean and
and so so sometimes i'll i'll do like a
you know
partner and in common like how you know
you're like
like
we all have like like if i have a lot of
clothes
you know that i i gained like say i have
over the year long i have
10 sweatshirts
and and then my buddy you know that i
trust and stuff you know he's got
10
20 pounds you know what i mean or
something like that you know i mean so
i'll be like okay i trust you you know
what i mean you know and so yeah you can
use my stuff and then it's the same you
know so we kind of shine you where do
you stay you're you're on a street with
a lot of rvs right
yeah
do you stay in an rv
uh no i actually uh
um i uh i hold down a large uh
a dark lodge i like to call it it's a
sort of a
um masonic uh
what do you call it
unorthodox masonic innovation uh i keep
outside lunch at red lodge i believe in
supporting the establishment
and keeping an eye on things from the
outside you know what i mean and
making sure that you know like uh
you know i believe in our economy and in
our establishment is this a tent that
you're in
uh yeah i stay in a tent or outside you
know it's usually my
outside you're often walking around
naked right
uh
no
no
that's your neighbors tell me you walk
around naked a lot oh i don't know i
mean like no
like maybe like close to i guess okay in
my bikini yeah
maybe that's what we're talking about
you know
and naked isn't bad though you know i
mean often like even right now i'm naked
you know i can't escape that part you
know i'm naked all the time
you know as we all are inside i was
thinking about that you know if if i had
to be really favored towards our species
as human beings you know in the
financial i'd have to say well it's
you know
let's make it safe for even you know
even a naked person can survive it and
be you know and do it you know
you know we come into the world like
uh we call it dependent codependent
already you know
and um
and then that part is something that uh
i find gratitude you know i mean i
learned that's that's where i'm at most
jesus you know i mean so
if it comes down to it like
um
that's what means a lot to me is the
people you've been living on the streets
for how long
uh
well i
i left
um already 30 years
i'm sorry third 30 years 30 years
how old are you now
uh 52 okay
do you have children
uh yeah i have a few i i i believe but i
don't know for sure because like i've
had some
uh
what do you call it uh
brain damage and like memory loss and
stuff like that and uh
uh i went into uh
uh
like i flatland a few times you know
what i mean and i had like it had its
toll on me like i've had i've got scars
and stuff like i've had a few head
traumas oh really from what uh
sporting to uh
you know
sparta
you know
so the streets are rough you know and
that's the thing is is learning and
struggling with you know with with with
people
you know
and learning how to function and
communicate and and
survive and even even on my worst day
be like grateful even on the worst dirty
drawer day
flat lined out of the hospital and
everything i was still glad to have
be able to participate in the struggle
you know what you don't read like you
know it feels good to help out you know
and that's what it's all about
and to see the progress like i i i've
watched this in l.a for the past
like
help lead innovation and change when it
comes to
uh
uh
being part of the solution in the
communities and finding things that work
and working with people you know i watch
things go from uh
a real struggle and desperate and
like really you know kind of like far
off to
you know everybody functioning and
working together and really making a lot
of progress and even
you know making it uh
leading for other people in the world
you know to say hey you know
hey you know there's solutions and stuff
like that you know what i mean so
um it was cool you know i i learned a
little bit from the whole pie theory
culture subculture
and slices of pie social economic stuff
and i was like
you
know it was cool to see see progress you
know and things like that like even for
me like i thought okay
it was like
there's solutions in the world where
where do they have this you know like
right now
this is like a long time ago you know
and drugs and all that stuff is like
you know it is like guns and you know
it's really you know i said it's like a
desperate thing it's like it's not even
really urine like it's not safe and all
that you know
what are they doing in amsterdam they
don't have a drug problem over there
what do you mean these people in in
in this in a culture over here
has been established a little longer
than our culture you know they found a
solution that's and that's when i
started getting into
like anthony robbins like you know like
i didn't really do a lot of it but i got
to hear him one time on the audio and
then uh
you know jesus christ was always a you
know innovator when it came to final
solutions you know what i mean
and i helped me like uh
you know i see the progress you know and
so i amsterdam said okay you know what
i believe that you know
we can make you know just because you
know
we have uh a
chemical dependency or or
we're a part of our subculture doesn't
mean we have to be
it doesn't mean that we can't function
within the other subcultures and be you
know just because i do drugs doesn't
mean i have to go around people and
steal and kill you know that that
doesn't matter what it means you know
what i mean you know or i have to be
like a womanizing you know stud you know
something like that but
uh you know it's just like
wow these people are functioning and
in in
uh drugs
and crime is a low low crime is a lower
rate over here and you know these guys
get along
you know
they're functioning they help each other
out you know there's no
they're not doing each other's scandals
so i thought you know that makes a lot
of sense you know
we could start
functioning and running our programs and
you know certainly would you describe
yourself as happy uh yeah i love you
i have to go over three days uh you know
since i last
you know three days since your last one
since i uh since i got my breath back
you know the breath of life i was
in the hospital every year well you were
yeah
and it was i got out what were you in
the hospital for uh i think maybe an
allergic reaction or maybe a chemical
overdose you know i mean it was the
wrong chemical that i you know maybe uh
i
may be messed up and do you experiment
with the drugs that are out here uh you
know yeah and you know and
possibly i have had an allergic reaction
at the same time
i was detoxing i mean it was a
combination it was one of those flukes
and so i go okay well that
they gotta be you know if i'm gonna be a
functioning jerry i gotta be more aware
of what i'm doing you know what i mean
and you know take care of my uh
you know be on top of it you know are
psychedelics some of the things that
you'll play around with sometimes uh i
don't i don't really
play with him like i
i i really believe in
a communion and community is how i
learned to
spiritually you know like i can be
sublimely mystical
you know
but then also
if i can take that
mysticism and somehow uh
find something that's practical out of
it and bring it back to the community
then my spiritual psychedelic
thing right that i went on that whole
trip for
uh it becomes a benefit to us in the
community if i could find something you
know you know i like tribal cultures and
i learned why would i do that you know
that sounds really cool you know like
these you know maybe uh lsd or or like
some masculine or something like that to
to uh
put you on a different state of
awareness and see how your mind reacts
right and what are you doing and i i
always stay close to god you know like
everything i do i do through god are you
religious yeah i have a very uh
uh
human you know
i guess you know people right god you
know we descend
or us in with god you know what i mean
looking at it
that's a great way of looking at it all
right you know so we are uh of the
original people that they talk about you
know the great tales and stuff that we
were actually ascendants from those
original people
so the all the things that happened in
uh
with the tribes back then you know could
very well happen with us
but i do know this
that the promises that things would get
better have always been there and
if we look throughout our histories they
always have gotten better and and
continue to make progress
i feel like life is better today than it
has been in the past
yeah you do yeah not everyone sees it
that way oh
well you know and that thing is i i hope
i i hope
for everyone you know that i hope
you know i looked at i tried to study to
find a balance on the overall
like
impact as part of the solution you know
i
mean
and i've tried to participate and be a
part of the solution for a long time
even coming from a subculture you know
such as mine you know like this
being part of solutions hey you know
this guy here he don't do drugs or
nothing you know what i mean but
they the the truck might break down and
some sort of they might need help
just because i'm getting hired now i'm
not gonna help these guys
or i can be
i don't have to
have my subculture
tear up other people's subculture you
know i mean people are into like their
venues and the citizens and that you
know what i mean and they come and help
help us out you know
and so like
oh yeah i'm willing to help out and and
i'll try to make it good for other
people too you know rubbing almost i
guess in the right way
what do you worry about what are you
afraid of uh
okay you know in life there's always a
question mark you know what i mean like
in the end i remember question mark
right and i saw that
acceptance
i learned was the key to all my problems
or solutions today you know i learned
that on the big book
and
also
you know when you have faith in god and
people and stuff like that that things
are going to work out sometimes it
doesn't all add up into my mind and i'm
like how's it going to work
but to go ahead and be able to okay you
know what i'm not gonna
lose my composure so i'm gonna just be
able to accept that and still try to
function move forward
and
that helps a lot you know like to be
able to
i guess fear would be like you know
you know i i i see the progress and and
and and i love people and i'm glad to be
alive people every day you know that's
you know
if i didn't make nothing at all but i
got to help someone out and you know and
in a period of time or whatever
that's worth it to me you know if i got
to participate in the past five years of
being a part of the solution in in in
in the overall uh impact
then
hey
i feel you know
do you stay in contact with your family
uh
uh yeah uh
well you know i've learned to
embrace
the people around me as my family and to
treat them as founding you know and and
to treat them as community
if you can't be with the ones you love
and then you love the ones you're with
and then you can be with the ones you
love you know so it's like
so like i know i talk to people about
you know sometimes about love and then
agape you know what i mean like there's
[Music]
you know obsessive like you know i i
love you guys i don't want it to happen
to you i don't want to lose you and all
that you know i mean and then there's i
want you all to myself you know what i
mean that's kind of a selfish way but i
understand where the feelings come from
um love is kind of hard to metabolize
you know you feel so much emotions
towards someone and it could drive you
one way or another you know what i mean
i guess
or you could just be content with it and
learn how to
you know
love the world that everybody's and you
know what i mean like just to say
if i loved someone
and i was in a relationship passionate
with them and then
you know that sort of died down i would
still love that person or if i'm not in
a relationship with that person and i'm
still passionate about them
you know at least i can
love the world that they're in
and you know even in those hardcore
places and times that they know at least
i know in my heart that there's good
guys you know in those places because
you know i have survived and been
through some tough stuff you know what i
mean and i know that the world
people have been there for me
and so i you know i i don't i have
confidence in the world that we live in
you know it's great what's been the
hardest point of your life um
i guess
the hardest part of my life
was probably
pacing myself
on a more of a a
a more of a long
you know not not an instant
gratification or instant uh investment
but
investing into the people
that you care about and into the
community
you know and i thought that was
something that you know
i know that if i was to leave today and
i you know it would that just the
thought of it would be like
you know i understood everything i mean
even
being back alive today uh
i i would know that
that the world is still gonna be good
place for people you know
has there been a period or something you
went through in your life that was
particularly difficult
yeah um
like uh
i've
haven't had a few uh
i've lost of family members and stuff
like that you know and uh that's rough
to go through
you know and then i've seen other people
go through loss you know
and
the biggest thing was probably
not being able to
hold up to
you know
whatever the the loss or or the struggle
might be you know what i mean and like
okay you know what
what can i possibly do you know it looks
doomed and all that but if i still love
and participate in a good way
i would still be doing the same good
thing that i would be doing no matter
where i was
you know
do you have any regrets in your life
i try not to hold resentments i i
learned that uh
in order to get where we're at
um
we had to come from somewhere and and to
hold the resentments from where we come
from
it would blind me to the possibility of
making good form in future you know and
i wouldn't want to hold resentments uh
towards
people
places and things which is simply
because
you never know what if you pass away and
what if what if like let's say
let's say
growing up i hadn't been saying
i i would say
for instance
man you know what i
how come these people
didn't do this this and that you know
but over here they did this and that you
know they should have better you know we
should have did this and this and then i
thought
okay
i'm not accepting it for one of those
people that i'm over here complaining
about
and resenting
i could be sitting here going oh you
know what they were facing struggles and
going through stuff at the same time too
and so you know what
hey it's better to have a uh
understanding and
an acceptance of those people and a
gratitude
you know because if if not for
our forefathers and and families and and
people we would not have made it this
far you know and so i have to
hold gratitude instead of resentments
you know if you had your life to live
over again is there anything you would
have done differently
uh
yeah i probably would have uh
probably would race motocross or did
like
you know been professionals tattooing
you know or like that maybe got into the
sensual arts you know like uh
you know some sort of uh you know exotic
uh
you know something or or maybe even uh
like uh
what do you call it a personal trainer
or like
or even uh
even a learner you're learning from
somebody like having somebody teach me
you know like maybe at some point
through life i go in and i learn things
and i again and i can share you know
like okay so even being the student was
a big accomplishment for me
you know
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
loyalty
loyalty and and and um
willingness to to do what it takes to
to
you know to help out and make it work
you know and and humbleness you know
it's probably one of the biggest lessons
and um
uh
what do you call it uh elbow room you
know and like you know okay you know
what these guys like you the certain way
you know
but they're still my people and i i
i would break my heart if i lost any
single one of them you know i mean or
and i don't want any single world not to
have a fun good life and enjoy their uh
humanity you know what i mean and then
their their uh
family uh in the world of of uh
of creation you know that we do we that
we are a steward to
uh in a sense you know and um
you know
i guess
a form you know i would practice the
same thing or practice you know
learning and growing and making better
form
certain things you know and then some
things i've uh
like my immune system
uh sometimes uh
i i stress it you know what i mean
but it gets stronger you know what i
mean there's other times though when i
would be like you know
i want to start you know that old habit
of building if i could do this that i
would you know
but at the end of the day i go you know
what
i can handle it and eventually we'll get
to that or i'll make an effort towards
that and i try to kind of uh
try to find the impulses in my self
to
move forward you know you know and i'm
i'm not perfect you know i mean i mean
it's perfect yeah i i got quirks and i
practice to try to make better i can do
better and try to get better for him you
know
so yeah
all right angel thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you i wish you the best of luck
all right thank you very much all right
you